Hi, and welcome to the Neil Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained some of the
fascinating ways
that science and engineering are changing
the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers from elite
level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some of the
world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics, machine
learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of discovery.
We also hear some of their life stories,
their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on the way that
I hope will be
helpful to you too. So sit back and enjoy
this
episode. Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast. Today, I think it's a pretty
special
episode. It's with really one of the
icons of CFD, Professor Antony Jameson.
It really is somebody who I'd always known
about, you know,
from the early days of me studying CFD and
speaking to
various people, it was clear that he was
somebody who was a
real pioneer. But I have to completely
confess
that I was I was learning a lot through the
conversation I had
with him. And as I was going through it, I
was blown away by what he has done and what
what it has led to
it. It's pretty incredible that he
was there at the beginning of both the use
of computational
fluid dynamics, but also the early days of
computing, the
early days of aeronautics, the
move to transonic, the sort of evolution in
aircraft design.
And it's amazing. And I purposely have
released it
today, which is his 90th birthday.
And so I consider this an episode to really
celebrate the
life and career of Professor Antony Jameson.
Just very briefly to summarise, he had an
incredible backstory
going into the British Army, being an
officer in the British
Army, living around the world in India,
Malaya, studying at
Cambridge, then moving over to to the US,
working with some of
the defense companies and aerospace
companies, writing
code, then moving to become a professor in
New York, then
eventually going to Princeton. But really
the overall and later
then he went to Stanford and he's now at
Texas A&M.
But what blows my mind is one, his
intellect, he's just the way
you can hear and speak about things.
But also the fact that when you appreciate
what he was writing
these codes decades before any of the codes
that we today take
for granted, the commercial codes, the
government codes.
And you really can see that it, it really,
I, I don't think it's
too far of a stretch of imagination to say
he was one of
the key people responsible for modern-day
CFD.
There's not many people who can say that
it's, it's incredible.
And yeah, he, he's known for certain certain
things, you
know, like adjoint methods, maybe for
aircraft design or
the, or some of the, the JST scheme shock
capturing.
But I think that that culture of writing the
code, getting in, in
the very early days, working with industry
closely, he was
not a pure academic nor a pure industry.
It was clear that he was always moving
between and you know, as
we discussed a little bit, but probably
didn't focus on too
much. Just the sheer number of people
that he has supervised and mentored who have
gone on to do
amazing things as top professors and and
engineers throughout the
world is a real testament to what he has
done.
Now this is a completely unedited, this is a
more than
two hour long conversation and I purposely
kept it this way to
not take anything away from what his his
life story is.
There were far more things we could have
spoken about, but I
wanted to be respectful of of his time.
I will put some links in the description.
If you're watching this on, on YouTube, it's
probably one that
maybe will take you a few times to go
through because, you know,
like I said, it's more than two hours long.
But yeah, I, I just have incredible honour
of being able
to, to speak to him. And I want to thank
him.
And hopefully I can say that on behalf of
everybody else to
thank him for his amazing contribution to
the field of
computational fluid dynamics, computational
aerodynamics and
scientific computing. So sit back and enjoy
this
episode with Professor Antony Jameson.
So, so where did it, where did it all all
begin?
So did you have, were you one of these
children who were always
into aircraft from a very young age, or was
this something that
that took age? How did this love of aircraft
and and later fluid dynamics begin?
Well, so actually, as a small boy—
So I can tell you the following story, and
of course it's just
my memory, but my father was a British Army
officer, so I think
he was sent to India in 1938 when I was
three years old, and
he spent six months in Bombay. But then he
was attached to the
headquarters of the British Army.
Remember, there was an Indian army, but
there was also
contingents of the British Army in India.
So the headquarters was in Delhi. But
because Delhi is very hot
during the summer, they moved to the summer
capital, Shimla, which is in the foothills
of the Himalayas at
7,000 feet. So somewhere around when I was
perhaps I've also had a nanny at this point
and she took my
brother and me. I have a brother who was one
year younger than me, but born on the same
day as me.
On a walk in Delhi. We went past a small
airport,
which I'm sure doesn't exist anymore, and
there was a, a
biplane there, a twin engined biplane,
something like a
twin-engined biplane, something like a
Vickers Valentia, if you want, but I don't
know exactly what it
was. But it was a biplane with
sticks and strings all over the place and
the engines in the
middle of each, between each pair of wings.
I looked at that and you know, I had been
looking at birds quite
a bit and I thought this is all wrong.
You know, birds don't have all these wires
and sticks and
things. But then it took another look
and I was looking at, I saw it had these
movable hinge surfaces
on the wings and on the tail. And I looked
at the tail and saw
that if you, I saw the wind bearing over the
plane.
I can't tell you why, but I saw that if you
push the elevator
up, that the wind would hit the top of the
elevator and push the
tail down. And that was my first time I'd
ever really had a close view of an aircraft.
Well, I can't have been more than about six
years old because
soon after that my father was sent to Iraq
and my mother spent
and my mother moved to Shimla on a full-time
basis.
And we lived in Shimla between 1940 and '43.
So my mother taught me to read and write by
copying over her
handwriting. She started teaching me the
tables when I was about 7 and I told her
that you don't need to
teach me this because I can work it out.
It's fairly obvious to me that you can, you
know, add seven and seven to get 14
and add seven again, it's 21. I can do that.
So at that point, my mother used to read to
us.
I haven't yet gone to school. I went to
school when I was 7
when my mother got pregnant at this Roman
Catholic mission
when my mother got pregnant, at this Roman
Catholic mission school in Shimla, but I
found an Observer's Book of Aircraft
with three-view silhouettes of things like
Spitfires and Messerschmitt 109s and so on.
And I persuaded my mother to buy this book
for me and I forced
her to read out of this book more or less
every day—sort of
wingspan, 36 feet and things like that.
So that was that. All right.
But we did. My father was spread first Iraq
and then Iran, and then he was moved back to
the front against
Japan, which by that time was in the not in
Burma but in the
North East of India. So when I was eight we
moved to
Shillong in northeast India and I went to
another of these Roman
Catholic mission schools for a year.
My dad wanted to have something to do with
the invasion of
Normandy and he applied to come back to
England.
So we came back to England in March 1944,
coming on a convoy
that went through the Mediterranean and then
went way
out into the Atlantic and finally landed in
Liverpool on a
horrible cold day and they managed to get
into luggage vans
or some train we travelled to some.
My father's sister was living in Sherborne
at the time when we
spent a few weeks there. And then I was
dumped in a
boarding school, a boarding prep school.
And the reason for that particular school
was that my
father actually had been a Wimbledon tennis
player and also
one of the world's best squash players.
And the owner of the school was somebody
else who had been on
the British national squash team that toured
America in 1934.
As far as I can make out, I was actually
conceived in America
during that squash tour. Anyway, I went to
this boarding
prep school that would normally be in
Brighton, but it was
evacuated to the Midlands during the war and
well, we had I was
put in the third form. It had 6 forms, so I
was nine.
I was put in the third form. But what
happened was that you
could be promoted each term. And each term I
came in the top
five and got promoted. So by the time I was
10, I was
actually sitting in the top form of this
school.
And I sat there for the next couple of years
kind of without
much to do because the teachers there, I
mean, these are during
the war and they were not the only people
available to teach,
were sort of retirees and so on. I think
that somebody, for
example, could have taught me calculus at
this point, but
there was nobody at the school who probably
knew calculus and
then wound up in 1947. My father applied for
a
job in New York for the what was going to be
the United Nations
Army, which never happened because of the
Cold War.
The reason he did is that my mother was
actually born in
America and we had American families.
So they went to America and they left my
brother and me going to
these boarding schools in England.
And we spent our school holidays with an
aunt, actually.
And I wound up getting a scholarship to
Winchester in
1948. And so that kind of had a big
And Winchester, of course, was
probably about that time considered to be
the best
academic school in England probably.
And at Winchester, I wound up focusing more
on physics and
chemistry, but I wound up eventually getting
a scholarship
to Cambridge. Well, we had state
scholarships
and county scholarships, but I also took
this open scholarship
exam in Cambridge. I went to Trinity Hall
because
my father had actually been sent to
Cambridge for two years as an
Army officer, but asked him what college he
was, he said Trinity.
And somebody at the War Office didn't know
that Trinity Hall
and Trinity were two different colleges.
So he went to Trinity Hall.
Sorry, decided I might as well go to the
same place.
But I didn't go straight to Cambridge.
See, we had national service in those days,
so out of Winchester
I went straight into the Army for two years
when I was 18.
And so now there's something else that's a
little bit
relevant to this. While I was at Winchester,
one
of the maths teachers was Doctor Thwaites.
Thwaites actually was a quite well known
expert in theoretical
aerodynamics and he he went on from
Winchester to become the
chair of aeronautics at Southampton
University.
Now I was never in a class taught by him,
but he organised
some trip to visit Super Marine in South
outside Southampton,
which is pretty near Winchester. And I told
him I was really
interested in aircraft. And he told me that
I ought to
read the book by Glauert, The Elements of
Aerofoil and Airscrew Theory, which I
don't know whether you're familiar with that
book or not.
So I managed to to get a copy, I'm not quite
sure how.
So now when I'm in the Army, I spent several
months in basic
training and then I passed this War Office
selection board for
officer training. So another six months on
officer
training, then you could apply to go where
you want.
And I applied to go to, to Malaya was then
called now
called Malaysia, right? So we went out to
Malaysia,
Malaya by ship. And I had this book by
Glauert.
I read it on the ship and I've still got
that copy of the book
in very tattered form. And you can see that
I've put
handwritten notes all over the place when I
tried to verify the
formulas. But this, this book actually
introduces complex variables and conformal
mapping.
So I actually learnt complex variables from
this book and
also conformal mapping. I've also learnt 3D
lifting line
also learnt 3D lifting-line wing theory of
Prandtl. So now I spent a year as a
Lieutenant in Malaya and I came back and my
father by this time
was back in England and he knew somebody
rather who had a
contact with Bristol Aero Engines.
So I spent six months from March to
September working at Bristol
Aero Engines before going to Cambridge.
So I was in a compressor design section,
about 50
people and everybody else in there had a
university degree.
But anyway, the first day or two somebody
showed me like it was a
day or two, somebody showed me how to use a
slide rule. We didn't—
This is before electronic computing had
really come in and
I went to a book. I bought a book on
thermodynamics and another one on jet
engines and read them in
a hurry. As it turned out, I could do the
job. I didn't didn't need a
university degree. Then the next thing that
happened was that we were supposed to do
these stage by
stage calculations as slide rules looking at
data from this
test station, which had something like a
25,000-horsepower electric
motors driving this and the test station
blew up.
Well, something got out of balance and
everything just tore
apart. So there was no data.
So it was a sort of stroke of luck for me,
because then they
had to think of something else for me to do
and I looked at
something called radial equilibrium that
flows in jet
engine compressors. And then finally I
actually
calculated the—they were testing, or had,
the first two-spool jet
engine, the Bristol Olympus, that went in
the Vulcan and
later was adapted to the Concorde.
And they had flight test data and they
didn't know what the
relative speed of the two high speed, high
pressure and low
pressure compressors would be. So based on
the flight
measurements of the RPM, I calculated the
combined
compressor characteristic for the whole 2
spools.
So that's before I got to Cambridge.
Before, yeah, yeah, before you went to
university.
All right. But by the time I got to
Cambridge, of course I knew quite a bit of
basic
aerodynamics, like I also knew quite a bit
about
thermodynamics. I know at Cambridge I wasn't
sure whether to try maths or physics or
engineering, but
seemed like the path of minimum effort was
to do what we called
mechanical sciences. At Cambridge.
When you take, if you have a scholarship,
you could take
what's called a fast course. It meant you
take the secondary
exams at the end of your first year and
basically your degree exam
after two years, and then for the third year
you do
something wants to be a kind of post
graduation, sort of like
approximately a master's degree. But but at
Cambridge I was
really, I thought they weren't teaching the
maths that we
needed, so they didn't teach vector
analysis, for example.
And so I started buying, they were various
quite inexpensive
books and I started buying these books on
things like vector
analysis and tensor analysis and so on and
trying to teach myself
anyway, I. Were you always a more than
maths person than an engineering?
Did you? Did you always have a a keenness
for maths? You know, in your earlier years
you said then that they didn't teach enough
maths.
Do you, do you have a very mathematical
brain?
Do you find maths comes very naturally?
Well, yes, I think it does, but I didn't
read maths at Cambridge
and maybe I should have it actually I have a
younger
and maybe I should have. Actually, I have a
younger brother who was eight years younger
than me, and he did
read maths at Cambridge. And so anyway, I
but yeah, I'm
really interested in, well, for example, I
mean for the Greeks,
you know, people think about Pythagoras
theorem.
But the thing that's actually interesting to
me is a
consequence of Pythagoras theorem is that if
you have a
triangle with two sides of one, I mean right
triangle, then the
length of the third side is the square root
of two, and now there's no fraction that
when you square it can produce 2.
So you can prove that however large the
fraction is.
And the Greeks already knew this and it
really wasn't sorted out
until the 19th century when it had a theory
for real numbers
developed. Another kind of interesting
thing is that Euclid, he's known for his
geometry, but he
actually had a proof that there's no largest
prime number.
So they knew there was an infinite number of
primes
already, the Greeks. So this is not the kind
of
question that people designing aeroplanes
really usually
interested in. But I am interested in this
kind
of thing, and there's set theory, which is
basically the theory of
what's progressively larger infinities.
There's countable numbers and then there's
the real numbers
and so on. There's a theorem that the set
of all subsets is larger than the original
set, which means it
could get a whole hierarchy of these
transfinite numbers.
So yeah, this kind of thing continues to
interest me, but I
was also still interested in aircraft and I
was very lucky in
the following sense that in England in those
days, well
under the Labour government, they tried to
make
opportunities, firstly for people to get
into universities.
But secondly, if you got first class
honours, your degree
exams, you automatically got support from
the Ministry of
Education to do doctoral studies, so they
would pay the full
tuition and lodging to any university who
was willing to
accept you as a graduate student.
So of course I was able to take advantage of
that, but I didn't
really want to to leave Cambridge.
really want to leave Cambridge. So I had to
try to find somebody inside Cambridge who
was doing
something that interested me. And I wound up
finding Arthur
And I wound up finding Arthur Shercliff, who
later became well known—
a Fellow of the Royal Society and so on. But
at the time I knew he was
only seven years older than me and had just
been made a lecturer.
He was doing magnetohydrodynamics.
So that's what I wound up doing in my
thesis.
But and then about one year into the thesis,
I was lucky that I
was in kind of invited to apply for what's
called a research
fellowship at Trinity Hall. So research
fellows at Oxford or
Cambridge are people who are actually are on
the governing
bodies of their colleagues. I mean, it's a
sort of pseudo
faculty kind of position. So I had a
three-year fellowship at
Trinity Hall. Actually I had a slightly
difficult start because I had been getting
my grant from the
Ministry of Education every three months and
that was paid
in advance. And then as a researcher it
turned out that I was going to get paid
quarterly, but in
arrears. So I had like six months and I
had to ask the bursar of the college to give
me a loan
because I, I. So the other thing is that my
advisor, Arthur Shercliff—so he went on an
exchange to MIT in my
third year as a doctoral student.
So at this point a student who was one year
ahead of me became
my nominal thesis adviser. And I actually
did an experimental
thesis and tried to generate Alfvén waves in
liquid
sodium. My thesis by the way you can
find on my Stanford homepage. I wound up
building a ten-tonne
magnet and things like that and we needed
300 amperes of
current, 200 volts. And there was a motor
generator
set from a World War II submarine in the
lobby of the
engineering department. And I managed to
have that moved
into the lab and use that to supply the
current for this
magnet. After all this, I
realised firstly I did not think I should be
doing experiments.
I felt very uncomfortable trying to
interpret sort of
pictures and oscilloscope traces. I didn't
actually think
hydrodynamics is going anywhere in
engineering, so I didn't
really know what I wanted to do. And then I
had some sort of
interest in politics. I was quite upset when
Macmillan
stepped down as Prime Minister and
engineered Lord Home
becoming Prime Minister and I thought, well,
maybe I should
get involved. The Trades Union Congress
advertised at the time for people to work in
the economics
department, and I sent in an application and
they decided
they would interview me. So I had about 3
weeks to read
as much as I could about economics in a
hurry.
And then I had an interview with Len Murray,
who at that time was
head of the economics department but later
became general
secretary. He wound up hiring me as an
economist working for the Trade Union
Congress, and it was quite
interesting actually. They had what they
called
National Economic Development
Councils—NEDCs—which were one-third
government, one-third management from
industry and one-third union reps, and were
supposed to be discussing how to improve
things, different
industries. So I was actually preparing the
position for the trades unions on the
aircraft industry and the
electrical industry, but I knew that I
wasn't going to be long
term a trade union person. I found it, it
was interesting
and actually I did a kind of study of what
happened to rates
of inflation versus unemployment and going
back to about 1900 and
I found that interesting enough the fastest
rate of inflation in
England was usually on the downside of each
economic cycle.
And that's because as far as I can make out
costs went up on
the downside because there was less
utilisation of the
factories and so on, and companies had to
pass the higher
costs straight on in higher prices. I've
certainly concluded that
this idea that there's a sort of non
inflationary rate of
unemployment is is wrong and actually
morally wrong as well
as practically wrong in my opinion.
I mean, deliberately having a high rate of
unemployment in order to
prevent inflation is actually sort of a bit
like human
sacrifice used to be to some prehistoric
god.
You know you sacrifice somebody for the
benefit of everybody
else right. But anyway, quite by chance
there was an advertisement in one of the
London evening newspapers
saying that Hawker Siddeley Dynamics was
looking
for engineers and they would have some
representatives of the
company in a hotel. Happened to me about 5
minutes
walk from the Trades Union Congress.
So I decided I might as well walk in there
around about 5 in
the evening at the end of the day and had a
very weird
interview. So there were two people in the
room. One of them said, what do you think
I can do? I said I think I can do
aerodynamics. The other guy said well what
are
you doing now? I said, well, I'm working as
an
economist. So then there was complete
silence for about two minutes. Then one of
them said, well,
what makes you think you can do
aerodynamics?
I said, well, I have a PhD in
magnetohydrodynamics and I
think it would be relatively easy for me to
do aerodynamics.
So they thought about that for a bit.
They finally just said, well, would I be
interested in coming
to the factory, which is in Warwick
basically exactly what
used to be the Armstrong Whitworth company
during the
Second World War made some very bad
airplanes.
There was a bomber called the Whitley that
sort of flew nose-down.
But anyway, I said, well, it would depend on
the salary.
They said they didn't know what the salary
would be.
I said, in that case I don't, I don't know
whether I'm
interested in coming for an interview and I,
I didn't
certainly hear from them again, but but
suddenly about a month
later they wrote to me and asked me if I
would go up
there. So I finally travelled up for
about a couple more interviews and the
outcome was that they
decided to offer me a position as chief
mathematician of this
Hawker Siddeley Dynamics in Coventry.
So actually not reporting to the head of
aerodynamics, but on a
level or even above him. So I thought, well,
I got to try
this. So I wound up at Hawker Siddeley
Dynamics. And—
And how old were you then? Well, that was
1964, I guess.
So I was just coming up to SO. You were
3030.
Just approaching that, yeah. Yeah.
So actually, incredible. When I got to
Hawker Siddeley
Dynamics, the first thing that happened was
that the guy who
had kind of initiated hiring me, head of
aerodynamics, a guy
called Malcolm James, told me that he
decided to leave and was
going to work for Douglas Aircraft in
California.
So I had expected that I would collaborate
with him, and that
didn't happen. You see it only overlapped a
couple of weeks, but I did, I did quite a
lot of antenna
calculations for example. And again, if you
go on my
homepage, you can find some Hawker Siddeley
reports, which
show the kind of thing they were doing at
the time.
And well, what I concluded was after I'd
been there about a
year was that they were never actually going
to build another
missile. They were making anti aircraft
missiles and they had this thing called the
Sea Dart.
And I didn't think we were ever going to
build anything.
So I finally decided, well I've either got
to get out of the
aircraft industry or I have to come to
America, one or the
other because British aircraft industry
didn't seem to be going
to build anything anyway. Every project got
cancelled by
the government, sometimes even when they got
to the point of
flying. So finally I had some interview
actually, I think, with the Central
Electricity Generating
Board and for some teaching positions
somewhere.
I'm so lucky I was turned down by both of
them.
But, and then I went on this, I can't quite
remember, but at
that time Boeing, Douglas and so on were
recruiting quite heavily
in in England. Well, I knew that they had
teams
in England. Well, I knew that they had teams
in England, and I wasn't interviewed by
Boeing or
Douglas. And I probably thought I would
probably rule out because they wouldn't like
my trade union
background. But finally Grumman, who I
didn't
know a great deal about, but they made these
sort of fatter
fighter planes during the Second World War.
They said that they were interviewing in
London and they
in fact decided to invite me to an
interview.
So I wound up hitting it off rather well
with the guy who
interviewed me, and he said, well, would I
like to be in what
department? I said, well, the research
department at Grumman. He said, well, he
didn't
represent the research department, but he
could
recommend me to one of the aerodynamics or
thermodynamics
this kind of thing. So I finally accepted an
offer
to work in the aerodynamics department of
Grumman on Long
Island. That didn't start very smoothly
the day I got there. Well, firstly, they had
a kind of—
outside the main Grumman sort of campus—
a plant where people who hadn't got security
clearances were parked. So I went, I
reported to this
department. There was an Englishman in
charge who said he was very sorry, but they
didn't have any
free desk for me to sit at. I mean, they had
about 150
people in there sitting side by side, but
there was no free
desk. Wow. So then they said, well, the
best thing to do is we'll send you to be
interviewed by the
head of the aero department. I had to be
escorted by a cop.
So I got to see this head of the aero
department.
His name was Bill Murphy.
And his opening words were that it had been
a mistake to hire
me, that he didn't have any need for anybody
with a PhD,
that he had had somebody with a PhD there
the year before who was
arrogant and lazy, and that he had no need
for me.
So this didn't seem like a very good start.
But then he handed me off to one of his
group leaders, a guy
called Rudy Mayer. So they had control
systems inside the
aerodynamics department because, if you have
something like a fighter,
then the aerodynamic stability depends a lot
on things like
dihedral and so on. So it's not just black
boxes.
So Rudy Mayer—I met him and he turned out to
be an extremely
nice guy who was actually a veteran of the
Korean War.
And he said he thought it would be
interesting to look at Horowitz's
method of designing control systems, or
stability
augmentation systems. I'd never heard of
Horowitz.
So I sort of thought about it a bit.
I countered. I said, look, I think it's very
interesting to look at the
issue of control systems, but why don't you
let me go away and
do a little bit of research for a few days
and I'll come back
and make a recommendation. So he he agreed
to that.
Now I'm not quite sure how I managed to find
the literature,
but, I mean, Grumman had quite a good
library.
I suppose they may have allowed me into it.
But anyway, when I met Rudy the following
week, I suggested that
we try linear optimal-control theory.
At that time it was quite new, pioneered by
Kalman in
particular, who was famous for the Kalman
filter, and really went
along with that. So I started looking at how
you
would apply linear optimal control theory to
designing
control systems for fighter aircraft and
suchlike. In actual
fact, Grumman was also building this
airborne early-warning plane, the E-2A
Hawkeye, with the big radome on top of
it. And so that had really awkward
stability characteristics. So the question
was,
could you design something that would make
it flyable? And what I actually got into was
that you don't necessarily—optimal control
requires you to
measure everything. I mean, it's fairly
obvious
because you can't really have an optimal
control if you can't
predict the trajectory. So if you express
the system of
the first-order system of differential
equations, you
need to know the initial conditions for each
variable.
In other words, if it's a feedback system,
you need to
measure everything the full state.
But actually to make a workable control
system, you don't
necessarily need that. So you can try to
make a what
would be in some sense a suboptimal system
nowadays, a
what would now be called sparse control,
where you restrict the
number of permitted feedbacks. And actually
for lateral control
of an airplane, for example, you don't
really want to measure the
roll angle because otherwise if you roll
360°, the control
system will try to roll the whole way back.
It doesn't recognise it. All right, so
nowadays, you
know, quite a mathematical theory for sparse
control, but I
wound up actually publishing about 15
journal articles and
control theory over the next few years.
Some other strokes of luck at this point,
because there was
a scientist called John DeYoung, who was an
ex-NASA guy, who
was developing a theory for predicting very
high lift
aerodynamics, what we call V/STOL aircraft.
It was a thing like the Breguet 941 that had
these big propellers
and then it has flaps to try to deflect the
propeller slipstream
to take off in a very short distance.
So John DeYoung had got a contract from NASA
Ames to
develop this theory, and then he was married
to a Brazilian woman
who wasn't very happy, apparently.
He asked for a leave of absence for three
months and then he
didn't come back. So Grumman got a message
from
NASA Ames saying, what's happened to the
contract?
The PI appears to be now working for
Ling-Temco-Vought, which the
government didn't know. So now there's a
crisis.
The head of aerodynamics said, well, we
should just give up on
the contract. And he was overruled by the
vice
president of engineering, who said we can't
tell NASA that
there's nobody else is able to do it here.
At this point. It turned out that having
someone with a PhD was a little bit of an
advantage that they
asked me if I was willing to take over the
contract.
I said, well, I don't really want to, but we
need to, as long
as I'm also allowed to continue doing some
work on this control
system theory. So they agreed to that.
But now when I looked at DeYoung's theory, I
thought it was
actually not quite right. But I came up with
fixes and
kind of convinced the, I said, well, we have
to write a
computer code also. And the first reaction
was that
that'll cost you much. And I went out to
NASA and said,
no, I can write this in within the cost of
this contract.
So that meant that at this point I felt that
I was being
underpaid by Grumman because I knew that
people with my level
of experience were getting quite a bit more
by just by reading
the job advertisements that used to come out
in the Sunday
newspapers. I wound up having an interview
with an outfit called General Research based
in Santa Barbara,
who were trying to develop an
anti-ballistic-missile system.
They offered me a job and my first reaction
was to say yes.
So I gave Grumman notice on a Friday, and on
Monday I was
called in before the VP of engineering who
said that he was
retrospectively raising my salary by 30%
from the beginning
of the year. Would I reconsider?
So I said yes, but I don't really want to
just do
dynamics. I mean, I want to look at a
broader picture. And finally, they created a
staff position for me where I reported to
the manager of
Flight Sciences, a man called Stu Harvey.
Stu first asked me if I could try to design
a wind tunnel
that Grumman might build. I looked at this
for a few
months. I don't really believe that
Grumman was ever going to go anywhere with
it.
Well, then all of a sudden, and this is in I
guess like November
1969, Stu Harvey called me in and said that
we've got to do
something about supercritical wings.
And I said, well, what do you mean by
supercritical wing?
And he said, well, the wing that works well
in transonic flow.
And Whitcomb—at this point Richard Whitcomb
at NASA Langley
had made a big splash with what he called
supercritical airfoils
that managed to reduce the shock drag
transonic.
And Whitcomb was an experimentalist who just
sort of used a file to
change the shapes and so on. And Stu Harvey
says, well, we
can't depend on Whitcomb's file. So I said
to Stu, well, look,
this is actually very interesting.
I said there's a aerospace sciences meeting
being held in
New York in January, and maybe I should.
After all, Grumman's 40 miles from New York
City.
And I said maybe I should go to this and try
to find out what's
being done in transonics. And I went to this
meeting and
Earl Murman presented what became quite a
famous paper on
calculating a solution to the transonic
small disturbance
equation. And The thing is I knew very
well that transonic flow cannot be treated
by linearising
anything. So you have linearised subsonic
equation called the Prandtl–Glauert
equation, or you have linearised
supersonic flow. But those what happens in
transonic flow is it it's actually an
elliptic equation in
the subsonic part of the flow field and
hyperbolic in the
supersonic part.
You can only get that change in type in full
nonlinear equations.
And there were books, for example, by
Oswatitsch and Lipman Bers—
attempts at analytic solutions of transonic
flow that had
basically gone nowhere. So I knew that you
had to do
this by some kind of numerical calculation,
and I also saw that
computers are getting just fast enough that
you actually
probably could do some useful calculations.
So that was kind of my chance to try to
solve the problem.
This was a pivotal moment. Just at the right
time, down in
the right it. Seems like you had, but you
had
a build up. I, I, I assumed that from an
early stage of your career that you were
working on transonic
flow, but you almost had 36 years of
build-up to this point
to then be given the opportunity to, to
focus on this.
Yeah, well, the answer is no. I hadn't
actually worked in
transonics at all, and I knew very little
about it, and I didn't know
much about numerical methods.
I'd never taken a course in numerical
methods, but I had
learned how to solve partial differential
equations as part
of my thesis, because when I did this
magnetohydrodynamics,
I had to solve this. I solved the equations
for these
Alfvén waves by separation of variables and
expansions in
Bessel functions and things like that.
So I had some background in PDEs.
I'd never taken a course in PDEs either.
But now that I realised that you could do
something numerically,
turned out that nobody—the head of the aero
department at Grumman—
wasn't willing to put anybody on to this.
I finally decided I'd better try to do it
myself, so I started
trying to write computer programmes for
fluid flow and I
didn't. I knew I had to learn more about
numerical methods. So I managed to get hold
of a
book by Richtmyer and Morton called
Difference
Methods for Initial-Value Problems, and that
was very hard
for me. It talked about things like Banach
spaces
and so on. I never heard of, but I fought
my way through this book. And then what we
needed to do
was not to solve the small disturbance
equation because
they're not small disturbances. When you
have a supercritical
airfoil or wing. So the best model was to
use
what's called the full transonic
potential-flow equation.
I ruled out trying to solve the Euler
equations because you
didn't have enough memory on the computer at
the time.
To do a 3D potential-flow solution,
You just got to store 1 variable instead of
like 5 variables if
you're solving the Euler equations.
And so I could see that we could actually
write a computer programme
that would work. And in the meanwhile also I
had
discovered that there was a group at the
Courant Institute led
by Paul Garabedian and I went in to meet
them.
Paul Garabedian had a student called David
Korn. They had
developed a method of calculating so-called
shock free
airfoils in transonic flow by transformation
to the hodograph
plane and then a method of solution
so-called complex
characteristics, due to Garabedian and Korn.
But I got
to know them and I thought that we could
solve the full
transonic potential-flow equation, but you
would need to use some
kind of conformal mapping so as to map the
flow outside the
airfoil to the flow inside a unit disk.
Well, I had the background in conformal
mapping
way back to the Glauert book. So I wrote
codes to solve
two-dimensional incompressible inviscid flow
by conformal
mapping, because my first code was FLO1. But
I envisaged a sequence of codes that would
become progressively
more complicated, more complicated
geometries go to 3D
and so on, and eventually go to solving the
Euler equation.
So in FORTRAN at the time you were not
allowed more than six
characters in a variable name or a programme
name.
So I truncated FLOW to FLO to allow for
three digits.
And after, about, about sometime during 1971
or after, I managed
to get a flow solver for transonic potential
flow
working. And at this point, Paul Garabedian—
I had persuaded Grumman to hire Korn as a
consultant.
So we had some contacts and they'd also been
writing an
analysis code. And when they found out that
I'd
And when they found out that I'd written
mine, that appeared to work as well.
Paul asked me if I would spend three months
at the Courant Institute as
a visitor and I thought I said yes.
I realised that I'm not going to be able to
do this
in the long run at Grumman, so I had to
consider moving
into academia somehow. And so I went there
for three
months and then Paul kind of tested me in
various ways during
that time. And then he said, well, why
don't you stay here? And he said, well, I
can't just
disappear from Grumman and I have to go back
and give them
notice. But I agreed and he had me as a
senior research scientist. That's in 1972.
And he told me that there's no faculty
positions going to be
available at the Courant Institute, but if
you make a
splash, you might get an offer from
somewhere else.
So I said, OK, I'll settle for that.
So when I got to the Courant Institute, I
started working for
Paul who he agreed that I would try to write
a 3D solver for the
transonic potential flow, but he wanted it
to be for a yawed
flying wing because he had a contract with
R. T. Jones at
NASA Ames. R. T. Jones was advocating that a
supersonic transport aircraft be just a
flying wing which would
fly at a skew angle—a so-called yawed flying
wing.
Of course, that never actually happened, but
meanwhile Paul
also had a contract with NASA Langley
because Whitcomb also
understood that if you could calculate
transonic flows, it
might help him to obtain better
supercritical airfoils.
So I wound up being the point of contact of
both Archie Jones and
NASA Ames and Richard Whitcomb at Langley.
And both of them sort of encouraged me.
They, they said move, Jameson move.
But that's so that maybe I could take this
further.
So then another thing that happened was that
I'd only been
at the Courant Institute a week when
they—they
didn't, they didn't take teaching very
seriously there.
But what they did do is they taught a lot of
courses in the
evenings because they were accommodating
people who were
working in the city who wanted to study
nights.
Turned out that the graduate numerical
analysis course was
normally taught by Isaacson, who's a
co-author of the book
Isaacson and Keller, which is quite famous.
And Isaacson was on leave and they hadn't
got an instructor.
So they asked me if I would like to try to
teach it.
So I said yes, I can try. That was that in
some sense is a
That was, in some sense, a stroke of luck
for me, because I didn't really know
numerical
methods other than the book I mentioned I'd
read by Richtmyer and
Morton, but I had to teach from Isaacson and
Keller. It really
meant I had to read the book ahead of the
class.
But by the time I'd done that, I had a
pretty
thorough knowledge of numerical methods.
So then after two years, the maths
department at UCLA was
interested. I got an approach and well, they
turned out that they were really more
interested in trying to hire Paul
Garabedian, but it was the kind of
suggestion that they would
hire both of us and they offered me full
professorship at UCLA,
but never in writing. But that's what was on
the table
at this point. The Courant Institute decided
to
respond by eventually the first offering me
an associate
professor. I said no, I'll take the full
professor at UCLA. So then they did offer me
a full
professorship. So it turned out kind of just
like that.
So I've never been in a an assistant
professor or an
associate professor; I went straight from
senior research scientist—
Straight to the top. So after that I was no
longer
working directly for Paul Garabedian, but of
course we
remained in close contact and I went on to
he'd.
Actually another thing that happened was
just before I got
that offer, I had written this FLO17, which
did a
three-dimensional flow past a yawed wing.
But I knew perfectly well that aircraft
engineers were never going to
build a yawed wing; what they needed was a
swept-wing code.
So Paul had another visitor from McDonnell
Douglas,
a guy called John Dahlin. John said, we need
a swept-
wing code and a nacelle code. I said, yes, I
know that.
I said, look, I can write the codes for you
if you'll help me
debug them. So I wrote the two codes.
FLO21 was for a nacelle and FLO22 was for a
swept wing.
In a few weeks, actually. Each was a box of
cards.
You know, we were still using card readers.
We had this Control Data 6600, which was
kind of the world's
fastest computer at the time. That's because
Courant had all
these contacts with people like von Neumann
and it had the
so-called computer centre in the Courant
Institute, which would get
the latest computers. But the 6600 was fast
by the standards
of the day. But it only had 130,000 words in
memory. Those were 60-bit
words, which turns out to be about two
megabytes.
So you couldn't really do a 3D calculation
and store it on the
core memory. You had to go plane by plane
reading off the disk. Anyway, so I wrote the
two
codes, and then John and I went to see Paul
Garabedian and
he was furiously angry. He said I was
supposed to be
helping him write his book on supercritical
wing sections and I
was only interested in being famous and so
on.
And I said, well yes, I'd certainly like to
be famous, but
actually I really need a threat to encourage
me.
But John Dahlin felt he
couldn't risk confronting Paul and trying to
debug these codes or
help me. And so I decided perhaps
we'd better leave it alone for the moment.
So the two boxes of cards remained on the
floor of my
office at the Courant Institute for the next
few months.
I never tried to run either of them.
And then when John went back to Douglas, he
told them that these
two codes existed but hadn't been debugged.
And then I got a call from a guy, David
Caughey, who was
working for the McDonnell Douglas Research
Centre in Saint
Louis, saying that they had somebody coming
for the summer
and would it be possible for them to have
this guy see if he
can debug FLO21. So I said that's fine.
And I flew out to St Louis with the box of
cards for
FLO21 and gave it to them. Well, this guy
did nothing that
summer. But then in the fall of '74, David
Caughey was suddenly offered a position as a
visiting assistant
professor at Cornell. They'd had a crisis
because two
of their top people had both left,
so David asked me if he could
take FLO21, and I said sure. So a few weeks
later he called
up to say that he'd fixed FLO21.
It was working. And I said, well, you're
interested in FLO22? And he said yes.
And I said, well, the thing about FLO22 is
it's got all these
analytic transformations and the huge, very,
very complicated
formulas. We need to have some independent
checking of this. I said, so are you willing
to
try to work out all the formulas separately
from me?
He agreed to do that. And then we had a
meeting and
came to New York and 1st his formulas looked
different from
mine, but then we found they were
equivalent.
So I gave him FLO22 and he took it back with
him to Cornell.
Called up a week later to say, well, he'd
fixed that too, and
turned out that I had got a miscount on
reading plane by
plane off the disk and writing updates back
onto the disk.
But he fixed that and the code worked.
So FLO22 was really the first computer
programme that could
calculate transonic flow solutions for wings
with
reasonable accuracy. In those days it took
several
hours to run a calculation on a Control Data
6600, but Douglas
attributed a cost of about $3,000 to each
run.
But they started running it about five times
a day when they
were using it to try to design the C-17 wing
and things
like that. And then Canada was trying to
develop what became the Canada, what do you
call it?
Well, now it's Bombardier, but the regional
jet—and they wanted
to use FLO22, but they found a consulting
company in Los
Angeles who was running FLO22 for them.
And this Canadair Regional Jet was the first
commercial aircraft
that had a supercritical wing. It was
designed using
FLO22, and eventually NASA released a
listing of the code
on some NASA website and it wound up being
picked up by the
Russians and the Chinese and everybody.
So the other thing that was kind of unusual
about my career, right,
I was a professor now, nominally of computer
science, at the Courant
Institute, but I didn't have any students,
you know, the people,
the students all wanted to work with the
famous professors like
Peter Lax or Louis Nirenberg or Jack
Schwartz.
You know, we had ten members of the National
Academy of Sciences
at the Courant Institute. So I had no
students.
So the only way to continue is to go on
writing the programmes
myself. And I had this collaboration
that developed with David Caughey, and then
we managed to get
support from the Office of Naval Research to
go pursue this
further. So I realised that we couldn't
really use analytical transformations to do
anything
more complicated than a wing–fuselage.
So we, David and I developed what we call
the finite volume
method for transonic potential flow. It was
really a finite-
element method with trilinear isoparametric
elements, but I
didn't know that at the time. And then I got
into the going to
the Euler equations kind of again by sort of
circuitous
route. I went to various international
meetings those days, something called
Symposium Transonicum 2
that was held in Göttingen at that time.
There was a Wolfgang Schmidt who was a
rather charismatic
character who had a small group doing CFD at
Dornier. Well,
Dornier was a sort of nothing much of a
company that somehow
survived after the Second World War, still
owned by the
Dornier family, but Wolfgang was very
effective in getting
support from various German government
agencies.
I met him in Göttingen. In fact, he
persuaded me to try
to swim in the town's swimming pool, which
is very embarrassing
to me when it turned out that I had to rent
some kind of bikini
like swimsuit and I was required to wear the
cap on my head.
And the other cap available was a sort of
pink cap with feathers
or something. Wolfgang turned out to be a
star
water-polo player and an expert swimmer, and
he
He kind of forced me into the pool.
But anyway, a couple of years later he
persuaded me to come
and spend several weeks at Dornier.
This is 1979. And then in while 1979 there
was
a workshop in Stockholm which tried to
compare efforts to
solve the Euler equations with potential
flow solutions.
I participated in that. I saw that nobody
had a solver
for the Euler equations that reached a
steady state, and I
felt that it was wrong. You should be able
to get a
steady state. So in 1980, Wolfgang asked me
to come back and he had an Euler solver that
had been developed
jointly by Rizzi and Schmidt at Dornier, and
it wasn't working
all that well. It was one of the ones that
wouldn't get a steady state that had been in
his Stockholm
workshop. He asked me if I'd like to look
at it, and I said sure. But I said, look,
did he really
want me to do this? We're going to have to
spend
several hours a day trying to do computer
runs and really to pay
for this. He said don't worry.
So Dornier had this IBM 4341, and they were
charging like one
Deutsche Mark per CPU second or something
like
that. And Dornier was kind of odd.
They had two men in an office, and they
would sit
facing each other. Each had a desk, but the
desks were pushed
against each other,
and you were looking at each other.
And they all called one another Herr.
They didn't use first names. And I showed up
and called Wolfgang
by his first name and they were all shocked.
But anyway Wolfgang said don't worry about
it.
So I actually looked at their solver and
decided that they'd got
some serious—we could call them errors.
They had a kind of, it was implemented what
was called the
MacCormack scheme, but they had an
additional artificial
viscosity term. And the way that was
constructed, turned out it was going to take
differences of the
cell volumes if the flow was uniform in the
far field.
And that's just generating big error term.
And so I rewrote the code. It was the first
step to what became the
Jameson–Schmidt–Turkel scheme in the next
year.
And at the end of the three weeks, Wolfgang
got a bill for
250,000 Deutsche Marks for the computer cost
of my visit there.
You see, his problem was not mine.
This is the point when I had been approached
by both Stanford
and Princeton with offers of faculty
positions.
And what had actually happened was that in
the academic world
they valued applied mathematicians basically
and
people like Milton Van Dyke and Mårten
Landahl at MIT, who did
all these asymptotic expansions and things
like that, but they
none of them had ever written a computer
programme or had any
interest in that. And I suddenly discovered
that
CFD actually worked quite well. But the
thing was that there was
nobody, not many people around who knew how
to write these
programmes, mostly from NASA, but none of
them had any
teaching experience, whereas I had been
teaching at the Courant
Institute. So I wound up being offered jobs
by both Stanford and Princeton and I went
out to Stanford and
and found they were offering me a $42,000-a-
year salary, and you couldn't buy a house
there for less than
about $400,000. And at that time the
interest
rate for mortgages was around 13%.
So it turned out that the $42,000 would just
about pay the
interest on the mortgage on the house. So
then I got approached by a
direct phone call from the president of
Princeton saying,
well, he'd like me to come down and play
squash with him.
I didn't know he was the New Jersey State
squash champion,
but I said OK, and eventually I took the job
in Princeton.
As a result, I went down and lost to him at
squash.
It didn't matter very much, but but this
1980 was in transition.
So I had got a first cut at this Euler
solver at Dornier, but I hadn't
got it yet to converge to a steady state.
And when I first got to Princeton, we didn't
have a
computer, and I convinced them that we had
to buy a minicomputer.
I would have gone for Digital Equipment, but
Princeton
was kind of IBM territory. So we wound up
getting an IBM
4341, which was the same machine as they had
at
Dornier. That filled a huge room with
cabinets all over the place, you know, the
disk and one cabinet
and so on. It actually had two megabytes of
memory. I had access to that from
roughly November, and I couldn't get this
thing to converge to
state. It would go down to some level
of error around ten to the minus three and
start oscillating.
I thought it was maybe reflection from the
far field
boundary conditions. That's when I consulted
Eli
Eli Turkel
That actually didn't fix the problem.
Then I tried running it 1st order accurate
and it converged
very well. So then I saw that I needed to
have but that was not accurate enough so
that I came up with
this idea that you blend fourth differences
and second differences
of artificial viscosity and use the fourth
differences as
background. But near a shock, that
causes an oscillation. So you turn them off
and drop to
a locally first-order-accurate scheme
through the shock.
And this is eventually what became this
so-called JST scheme.
got away with a lot. Yeah.
But actually for me something else happened
around that time.
So I I presented this JST scheme and by that
time I had got a 3D
implementation with FLO57 at the AIAA
meeting in 1981, in the
summer in Palo Alto I think it was and
nobody paid much
attention. But then of course the company
started getting my code FLO57, and they
found it worked.
But just about that time, Phil Roe came out
with his famous
paper with his so-called Roe
matrix—basically characteristic-
based—and it's a work of genius, that paper.
So that
kind of got the academic limelight that I
didn't deserve myself.
I don't deserve it yourself. But when I
tried coding the Phil
Roe's scheme, I found that it wasn't really
doing any better
than my scheme, but it wasn't really helpful
to to push that.
But what I did find out about the Roe
scheme, especially—you
had this mean-value matrix; it's called a
Roe matrix—and he
found an analytic way of calculating and
then.
So it's a stroke of genius and turns out
that that enables
analysis of other schemes, not just a Roe
scheme.
If you use this Roe matrix, you can actually
prove things about
the numerical shock structure, shock waves,
being in a shock
capturing scheme and so on. So it really
opened the way to a
much broader way of looking at sort of
theoretical side of
these schemes that well, I don't know where
you want to go from
there, but so we're in 1980. So what
happened?
Yes, so you would then at that time at
Princeton, one question
I had was the code. So you mentioned that
people
were using the code. You were, you know that
NASA
were using it different companies and we
Fast forward to
now and there are these large commercial
companies, you know,
Ansys Fluent and Siemens and all these
others.
Did you did you think about or, or maybe
this is what's coming
next, the commercialization of this or was
it very much at that
time this idea of the code was for everybody
to use.
It was sort of for the good of the
community.
Well, there are several things that I think
you need to
realize, you see. We didn't have copyright
protection of computer codes at that time.
Actually, that was only established by Bill
Gates around
about the early 1980s. So there was really
no way to
prevent codes being passed around.
But in fact, of course, if you wrote a code
that worked and
FLO57 wound up being used by just about
everybody in the
aircraft industry in America, and then it
got—well, Dornier
had it because of course I'd been working
with Wolfgang at
Dornier. But then I had a consulting
arrangement with Cray Research and I didn't
mention this, but
actually, when I wrote the 3D code FLO57,
which was in around
February or March of 1981, I could only run
a mesh of
like 48 by 8 by 8 on this IBM 4341.
But I had been approached by Cray Research
because they were now
trying to sell their first Cray-1 computers.
They got benchmarked typically by FLO22.
So they decided it might be better to have
me on board.
And I was interested too, because I thought
that this JST
scheme should vectorise without a problem.
So they gave me access to a Cray-1. When I
first tried to run it,
this code didn't vectorise.
And I went out there and discovered that
there were one
or two minor changes I still had to make to
the code, but it
would vectorise. But when I tried to write
FLO57,
I had a terminal at Princeton connected to
Cray
Research. So after I got it to run on
the IBM 4341, I was able to submit the same
code to Cray through this
terminal, and I could run something like 96
by 16 by 16.
It still wasn't enough memory on the Cray-1
at the time, but at
least that was enough to make a meaningful
calculation.
But now it meant Cray had the code.
So they were trying to sell Crays in Europe
and they sold
one to the British Royal Aircraft
Establishment and
another to the Dutch at NLR. They threw in
FLO57 as
part of the deal without my knowledge.
So this kind of got to Holland and England
and well, I didn't
get any money out of it, but I did get a
good deal of
recognition. And so now my sort of attitude
started to change around there because the
Air Force issued a
request for proposals to solve more
general configurations, and the obvious
thing to do was go with
some kind of multiblock extension of FLO57.
And bunches of
companies like Lockheed and Northrop and so
on all submitted
proposals to the Air Force, which amounted
to further
developing FLO57. And it seemed to me that
the Air
Force could have asked me whether I wanted
to further
develop the code rather than funding
Lockheed, which is what they wound up
doing. So I sort of started to
wonder, well, how are we going to get more
control?
But then I also knew that I wanted to do a
complete aircraft
calculation. And my first idea was that you
could use a multiblock mesh. But then when I
looked at how
hard it would be to generate these meshes, I
saw that we
didn't have anybody at Princeton who was
going to do that.
And by this time I had brought in Tim Baker
from England as
a research scientist working for me, and he
had his friend
Nigel Weatherill, who was working at the
Royal Aircraft
Establishment in Bedford. Nigel was
interested in spending
six months sort of sabbatical at Princeton.
The RAE were very worried that they had
developed a multiblock
extension of FLO57 and they were very
worried that Nigel
would bring it with him to Princeton.
Right. I said, no, I've concluded that
we have a better chance if we go to an
unstructured mesh.
So I told Nigel to forget about the multi
block code.
We were going to work from scratch with a
triangulated mesh.
When Nigel arrived I asked him if he could
By this time I'd
become aware of this process called Delaunay
triangulation and
I asked him if he would try coding it.
And he got it to run in 2D in a week or two.
So we could do, in principle, multiple
airfoils
and things like that. But then I had a
meeting with
Tim and Nigel. I said, well, I think we
should
try to do a complete aircraft. And the idea
was that Tim could
generate meshes around the different
components, rather
like an overset mesh. But then we would take
the
points from all these meshes, just a cloud
of points, and
triangulate them with Delaunay
triangulation, and that would be
our grid. And meanwhile, I wrote a flow
solver to work on tetrahedral meshes, and we
had an agreement
from Cray Research that they would support
this project.
But then we finally got a first version of
the code together.
We called it the airplane code. Turned out
that it used the
whole memory of the Cray. So they put it to
the back of
the queue. And then at the end of the day
they would turn the shut the machine down
and start running
experiments with operating systems.
So it just didn't run. So at that point I
tried to
contact John Rollwagen, who was the
president and CEO of Cray,
who had agreed to support this. He was out
of town, but I got
his number two. They agreed to let us come
out
and use the machine during weekends,
overnight.
And I also, I had a, because I was a
consultant, I had some
kind of immediate manager at Cray, and he
was very angry that I'd
bypassed him and he dismissed me as a
consultant to Cray.
I said, well, we still have access to the
machine.
As it turned out, I didn't care about that.
But we went out in July. We were given the
machine
at night during the weekend. So we spent two
nights—
we were up all night, two nights in a row.
It became
clear that Nigel's Delaunay triangulator
wasn't working, and
we couldn't really disentangle exactly why
not.
But then Nigel was due to go back to England
and so we
decided basically to put everything on hold
for a bit.
Tim and I had summer vacations, and I was
spending time at Dornier
again, but when we got back in the fall, we
concluded that we
couldn't debug Nigel's triangulation because
he was
doing some things that are not—well,
He kind of assumed that when you called a
subroutine that some
data values would still be there when you
recall the subroutine.
It's not actually the case in FORTRAN.
It depends on somebody's compiler whether it
is or, which
isn't still there. It was just almost
impossible to
figure out exactly what had gone wrong.
So Tim started rewriting a Delaunay
triangulator.
And finally in November we used to go out to
Cray because also
we couldn't visualise anything. But Cray had
these Evans &
Sutherland terminals where you could
actually take a look at
the mesh. Finally, one weekend, around
9:00 in the morning after we'd been up all
night, we saw
that we'd got a mesh that seemed to work.
Then Tim and I had to catch a flight back to
Princeton and we
barely caught the flight, but we were
upgraded to 1st class,
having showed up late and got free drinks.
That wasn't a really good idea. Then we got
to Newark.
I had this junk car that I'd left at the
airport, and Tim
asked me if I could drive, and I said I
thought so, but when we got
to the car and he just passed out.
I started driving and I discovered that I
just had
double vision, which wasn't really good for
me.
On the New Jersey Turnpike, basically, I
could get rid of the
double vision if I took my glasses off.
But then I decided it was kind of lucky that
we made it back to
Princeton without a crash. But anyway, we we
finally did
get a successful calculation for a Boeing
747 which we presented
at the Aerospace Sciences Meeting in Reno in
January 1986.
That was—well, at this point—a big moment.
Yeah. But I thought now I have to tell
Princeton that we'd got the code, because
Tim had been paid
full-time as a research scientist, not by
Air Force grants, but
by Princeton. And normally that meant that
any
code we wrote that probably belongs to
Princeton.
So I approached my department head at the
time and said, well,
I think this code actually has potential
commercial value
and it's also possible that you could patent
the numerical
scheme. Well, it turns out that
Princeton had signed some deal with an
outfit, some of the
small companies, to give them first right of
refusal for
intellectual-property rights to software
developed at Princeton.
And I got a call from somebody. I thought I
was talking to a
somebody from the legal department inside
Princeton, and
I was talking to these people and I told
them those things
that I probably would not have told them.
Anyway, these people sent a
form to Tim and me in which we agreed to
give them all rights
in perpetuity to the code and any
derivatives, for one dollar.
Tim and I refused to sign it. So we're not
going to agree with
that. And really nothing
happened because these people, we said,
look, we've written the
code, but you ought to patent it.
So they didn't. But meanwhile the code was
kind of in limbo for three years.
And then the rights reverted to Princeton.
And at this point, Tim and I went back to
Princeton and said,
well, look, the only people who can really
commercialise the
code are actually us, because we can—we can
make it work.
So he finally agreed to let us form a
company that we called
ESOP—Aerodynamic Simulation and
Optimisation. We would pay 15%
of the proceeds to Princeton. So then we
tried to market the
airplane code, but the thing was during
those three years, that's
when Fluent started to get going with its
mesh code.
So really we lost the window and I, I didn't
really want to run a
company where you, I mean, actually
commercial software has
a great deal of an issue of marketing, isn't
it?
And suchlike. I really cared about doing
calculations on some
swept-wing planform or something.
So, but we did, we did make, we did sell
about 5 copies of this
code—one to Douglas, where they used it very
seriously.
And John Vassberg became very involved.
Actually, he managed
to fix some issues with the code because it,
it was by that time
we had versions of the Cray with four
processors and things like
that. And for some reason this
Delaunay triangulation should have been
sequential when it was
running faster with the multiprocessors.
And John figured out that what was happening
was that there was
one particular process going on which was
consuming all the
time. It was—
So what this Delaunay triangulation, what
you do is
you have a triangulation, you insert one
more point and then
you re triangulate in the vicinity of that
point you add.
But Tim had some flags, and at the end of
each additional point
he was setting these flags back to zero
through the whole mesh, and
instead of just in the region where it had
been re
triangulated. It turned out that that was
90%
of the time the triangulation was spent
resetting these flags
to 0. And when you removed that, the
code ran in like 40 minutes instead of 30
hours
triangulating. But John Vassberg was kind of
responsible for its commercial success. He
used it
successfully at McDonnell Douglas to fix
some of the problems with the MD-11
nacelle–wing–pylon
interaction, things like that. But at this
time, I also came
back to my original first love. You see, I
never thought it's
just a matter of calculating the flow.
I thought we're trying to find the best
design on actually
going all the way back to 1970, I wrote a
code called SYN1
at the same time as FLO1, and SYN1 actually
solved the inverse
problem. You input the pressure
distribution and it finds the shape, by
conformal
mapping. But I'd never given up on this
thought. But this is where I I went to a
meeting at NASA Langley on flow control,
probably in maybe
February 1988, something like around that
time, kind of a sort
of light bulb went up in my head.
I suddenly realised, oh look, these people
are trying to do
flow control, but actually you could use the
control theory to
do shape design. In other words, the control
would be changing the shape of the boundary.
And I should have known this because I had
all the background
and control theory. But I think, see when I
did
control theory, I always did it for finite
dimensional systems.
This would be, I've said something by
mistake.
I'm not quite sure what's going on here.
Can you see the pictures still? I've got a
second little picture
of myself. I don't know why that happened.
Oh. I can, yeah.
I'm not sure. I can still see you and hear
you. You can see me.
Yeah, all good. Well, anyway, it sort of hit
me
that we need you could just use control
theory and well, that's
control of infinite-dimensional
systems—PDEs.
So I knew that Jacques-Louis Lions, this
famous French
mathematician, had written a bunch of books
on control of
PDEs. So I had to go off and try to
fight my way through some of this book.
Well, it's very, very difficult. It's all in
Sobolev spaces and so
on. But I got to enough just to
understand that you need to solve these
adjoint equations.
And so I came up with this aerodynamic
design by a control
theory of paper that I wrote, and later
that.
Yeah. And they did something that I'd
never done before. Aerodynamic design by
control
theory doesn't actually have any computer
programme in it at all.
It just develops a theory of saying if you
did this, it
should work. All right.
And I think I was partly reacting
to, I'd had feedback that people said I was
a good computer
programmer. And I said, well, OK, I'm going
to show you that there's a theory here.
I'm going to publish the theory first.
And I gave it to Steve Orszag, who was at
Princeton at the time,
and we were pretty good friends. And he was
just trying to start
this new Journal of Scientific Computing.
Because I knew that I felt it would help him
starting the
journal, and I knew that he would publish it
without my
having to fight by way of arguing with
reviewers and so
on. So that came out, and now nobody
seemed to believe me. I gave presentations
in various
places like NASA Langley and got blank
stares. I gave a seminar
at Stanford and just got blank stares.
So then I had to sit down and try to program
it myself and I
managed to get it to work for the transonic
potential-flow
equation. I actually first made a
presentation at the Israeli aeronautical
conference in, I think,
1989. And once I'd written a computer
programme which really worked, then of
course it started to attract
attention. And so that became my main focus
after about
1989 through 1995 or thereabouts. I
eventually—
And I guess that is— No, no, carry on.
Sorry.
Well, I think the basic thing is, you know,
I was basically
trying to solve the problem of a transonic
flow.
I wasn't really basically trying to develop
numerical methods as
such for their own sake. If you look at a
number of the
other people who've been big contributors in
CFD—Phil Roe,
Bram van Leer, Ami Harten or Stan Osher and
so on—none of them were
interested in aircraft. Actually, they were
interested in CFD as
such. Whereas, for me— Yes.
I was interested in designing better
aircraft, and in
particular the problem of transonic flow was
kind of
perfect for me because it was a combination
of mathematical
challenge and everything else. And how much
do you think that
your time in industry shaped that?
You know, you went from Cambridge then for
more than 10
years in industry before you eventually
moved to a pure or
more of a pure academic role in the in the
70s.
Do you think that industrial time made you
more focused on the
practical challenges rather than a purely
theoretical, you know,
research path? Well, I think yes, to some
extent. I mean, I was involved in, I
mean actually I didn't have much involvement
in any particular
design at Grumman, but I was, you know, I
was exposed to what was
going on. Of course, they were the main
project they had underway was this—the F-14
swing-
wing fighter—which I didn't believe was the
best solution
myself, but, but I used to walk around.
They still had draftsmen and drawing boards.
I used to walk around sometimes where they
had the draftsmen and
chat with people. You know, it was a plan
for some
kind of government, I think some kind of
regional jet, and the
starting point was to trace the three-view
drawings from the
Canada regional jet or something like that.
I watched these people doing it.
But I, yeah, I wanted to have a real role in
designing an
aircraft, and oddly enough it finally did
happen in a very
direct way when we got to the Gulfstream
G650 which was
designed around about 2006 so maybe I should
mention that to
you so. Yes, please.
Dating back to when Douglas was using FLO22,
Pres Henne was one of the really outstanding
engineers who
kind of climbed the ladder at Douglas and
eventually was the
programme manager for MD-95 and things like
that.
And I can't remember—the MD-90, I think it
was.
But then he became vice president of
engineering at
Gulfstream and he was particularly
interested.
Well, he developed the Gulfstream V, but
then in the early 2000s he was really
interested in developing a, a supersonic
business jet.
He had deals with the Russians, people like
Sukhoi
and so on. But so he actually asked me if I
would consult for Gulfstream and I said,
yeah, but actually I
believe I can help you more with transonics
than a supersonic
business jet. And then around about 2006,
they
decided to launch this G650, and Pres wanted
to have a plane
that could fly 7,000 nautical miles at Mach
0.85, but he also
wanted to fly 5,000 miles at Mach 0.9.
And they were having a problem because they
were actually getting
about 3,500 miles at Mach 0.9 according to
their first efforts
at designing it. Then Pres sent me an email
saying, well, would I like to try to to help
that or I said
yes. So I started working with Bob
Mills, who was the aero lead for the G650—an
Australian, tremendous
guy. And this interesting because it
really was an example of remote cooperation.
So I had this wing–body shape-optimisation
code, SYN107, and I
could run. I had a cluster in my garage in
this house actually. So I could run these
optimization calculations in a few hours.
And then I gave him an account on my cluster
and he could pick
up the geometries that I produced with
SYN107, and he would then
put that geometry into a solver for the
complete aircraft.
And they were using USM3D. But I could
actually come
up with optimised shapes faster than they
could do the analysis
at Gulfstream. But eventually it took
hundreds
of iterations because the question of
course, exactly what
to optimise and what we were trying to.
Firstly, it was clear that the original wing
design was going
nowhere. So I told, I told him that
Why don't I just put in my own wing
sections?
I had lots of wing sections that I'd
developed in
different sorts of studies. I just started
over,
And so he agreed to that. Then we found that
we could get
a wing which basically didn't have drag rise
to about Mach 0.88
and could fly at Mach 0.9 if you came down
to a lower lift
coefficient without a real drag rise or not
much.
And essentially the wing was designed kind
of semi
automatically by SYN107. So there's a
picture of the
two of us in I went to the first high speed
wind tunnel test of
this plane at NASA Langley's National
Transonic Facility,
the cryogenic tunnel.
There's a picture on my homepage that shows
the two of us inside
the wind tunnel with the model of the
airplane.
And yes, when we actually did the
actual high-speed run in this cryogenic
tunnel, it verified that
our predictions were correct, and it was a
completely new
level of performance for a long-range
business jet at
the time. So we left something on the
table because I wanted it to have slightly
more sweepback
in the wing, and Pres Henne vetoed that
because it was
the first plane Gulfstream designed that was
going to go fly-by-
wire, and he wasn't sure that they could
handle the lateral
stability problems if you had more
sweepback. And I
wanted to have the same sweepback as you see
on a Cessna Citation
X. And I think we could have taken
it just a little bit further. That's the one
time that I—
That's amazing.
Designing a plane, basically, yeah, yeah.
But during that time, do you think back, you
know, when you
were writing the code, you know, 2 megabytes
of memory, you could
barely fit something on to then still within
your career,
designing a whole aircraft—and designing it
in your garage.
Do you appreciate, does it still amaze you,
the development of
code and computers over your lifetime?
Yeah, well, I think the thing was I always
thought that you
had to look at what's feasible at any given
time, given
computer resources. In fact, I'm going to
tell you
one thing I learned in the British Army
doing officer
training. So they told us that in kind of
So they told us that in a combat situation
you have to make a plan, right?
So you said the first thing to do is to make
an appreciation of
the situation. You know, the enemy has
10,000
troops and you have 100. So a frontal
assault, for
example, is not going to work whatever,
right?
And then you have to, to find a goal, let's
say defeat the
enemy. But then you do a based on the
appreciation, you might have to refine the
goal to something
that could conceivably succeed. So you
iterate that a few times
and when you arrive at a goal that's
potentially feasible,
then you draw up a plan and you carry it
out.
So I would say that I kind of applied that
kind of thinking.
It was feasible to do 2D airfoils in 197071
and then by
the time we got to the 1980s, you could do
even 3D Euler
equations. And of course eventually, but I
had. So it took about 15 years to get
from 2D airfoil to a 3D Euler solution for a
whole aircraft, but
very much paced. We still didn't have enough
memory in 198586 for the full airplane.
By the time we got to 1990, that was kind of
beginning to be
fixed. But I mean, I could hardly
imagine the range of resources. I mean, this
machine that I'm
talking on has about, I think, 32 gigabytes
of core memory, a
terabyte solid-state disk. And it's also
actually about 100
times faster than the Cray-1 was.
So we're living in a totally different
world.
And now you move on to where do we go next?
Well, we still then have the solution to the
turbulence problem.
We have this large-eddy simulation, for
example, and
that still seems to be largely open—still
open—about how
to set about it. I mean, nowadays you have
these
buzzwords like scale-resolving simulations
and so on.
But I don't think anybody can calculate a
flow,
let's say, for a submarine at Reynolds
number ten to the ninth,
in an accurate way at the present time. And
I got
involved partly due to pressure from funding
agencies
and trying to work on high-order methods in
the last 15 years, I
think they can contribute. But I know that
you're very
interested in machine learning approaches.
I did get to make one stab at looking at
machine learning.
Some work we did just about last year.
I had left Stanford before I wound up taking
this job at Texas A&M,
because Stanford kind of forced me to
retire.
But we actually did write a paper with
Jeremy Morton and
Freddie Witherden, who was then my postdoc,
and Mykel
Kochenderfer, who was on the faculty at
Stanford, on machine
learning for trying to control vortex
shedding off a cylinder at
the low Reynolds numbers. And we were using
this.
I know of a so-called Koopman operator, and
I don't know
whether you're familiar with that or not.
But what Koopman did was to say, well, if
you have a nonlinear
process, let's say x superscript n plus one
equals some function of x
to the n—that's nonlinear. Then if you look
at all possible
functions of that solution, so-called G of
X, it turns out
that if you think of the update to the
solution G when
you do this nonlinear operation.
But that's linear in the sense that if you
have one function
G1 and another one G2, a linear combination
still works.
So what you do is you associate an
infinite-dimensional linear
operator with a finite-dimensional nonlinear
operator.
And then infinite-dimensional operators
might have a continuous
spectrum. But it could be that there might
be an invariant subset where anything in
that subset in the
linear closure of that subset stays in the
subset
through its nonlinear updates. And if you
can detect an
invariant subspace, it might have discrete
eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions and that can be used as a
model.
And we think that vortex shedding is an
example of
something where that might happen.
We did manage to come up with a control
system based on that
that kind of worked and got into NeurIPS.
Oh yeah. It has quite a few citations
already, but when I got to Texas A&M, I
couldn't find anybody
on the machine learning side to work with.
And it sort of fell by the wayside.
Well, I, I do think that somebody, maybe you
will succeed
in developing some kind of giant neural
network that will
probably predict turbulent flows reasonably
well within a few
years. Maybe not
while I'm around. The trouble, assuming that
you have some giant
neural network like these large language
models that could
predict a turbulent separated flow, then the
trouble is you
might not get any understanding out of it.
I mean, you can run the neural network and
it gives you some
numbers. It doesn't really give you an
understanding of what's going on
necessarily.
So that's my— Yes. Yes, that is the—
I don't know if you've come across this, but
at least what I
was told and, as you know, one of the dreams
for a
lot of these aerospace companies is digital
certification, being
able to actually get the approval to
certify.
But you have to understand how the code and
the method has got
to the answer. And I guess the risk with the
machine learning is it may be able to get
the answer, but if
you don't understand exactly how it did it.
Then it's probably not going to be suitable
for a certification.
So that still is maybe a challenge.
I think that's true. But of course there
are.
I mean, there are people like Steven Brunton
and Nathan
Kutz at the University of Washington, who've
made a lot of
progress detecting PDEs based on just
looking at data and suchlike,
like, but I don't really, well, I don't
know, I'm not too
worried because I think I don't really feel
that I'm going to be
replaced by some kind of neural network
while I'm alive.
That's a problem for the next generation to
grapple with.
So what would be your, what would be maybe
your advice?
So if somebody now is listening to or
watching this in
their 20s or their 30s or, or really at any
age and we're
going to, you know, wanted to make an impact
in the field of
aeronautics or CFD. Is there any things that
you've
learnt along the way in terms of your
mentality, the way you
approach things? You, you talked about the
British Army example, but is there any sort
of yeah, advice
you would give to people? Well, I think
really one of the
problems is that there are an awful lot of
people doing
doctoral studies in CFD at the moment, and
it's very hard to stand
out from the crowd. And I think what I would
say is,
in principle, if the crowd is going one way,
you need to go in
a different direction. But of course, you've
got to
find a different direction that actually
works, right.
Because if you go the same direction as
everybody else,
you're going to do the same thing as
everybody else, and
nobody's going to care all that much.
So the trick is to find a different
direction, which, if
you get it to work, will change the
direction of the field.
But that's not easy. Maybe.
Yeah. Well, there's a matter of luck also
getting into that just I think in my case I
arrived at
transonic flow at the moment when there was
a real
opportunity to do something and have an
impact and kind of hard.
Now. I mean I can tell you that as a
practical problem, we have all these
electric VTOL things like
Joby, and they have to make a transition
from hovering to
forward flight, typically by tilting their
rotors over.
And we're way short of being able to
calculate that by any
numerical method at the present time.
And seems to me so if that's somebody could
really solve that
problem, we would have a pretty big impact.
So tackle the hard problems, I guess you're
saying look for the
disruptive ideas, the difficult problems,
and if you can solve
it, you will have an impact. Rather than
taking the easy
incremental work, go for the, go for the
more challenging things
that, yeah. It would also be worthwhile,
actually, I would say. All right.
Well, firstly, of course, you know, the
whole issue of funding
is, I mean a lot of universities
specifically require people to
bring in money. At Texas A&M, they
even have prizes for people who bring in
more than $1
million of this, that or the other.
But The thing is, if you solve a research
problem, then that
basically determines the funding.
If you were to solve it, why should they
continue to fund it?
All right. Yeah.
So a lot of people have a sort of strategy
that they never
solve a problem. There's always light at the
end
of the tunnel where you might begin to solve
it in another
couple of years if you keep on funding it.
Whereas, you should go ahead and solve it
and move on
to something else. But then yeah, the trick
there
is all the work I've done that had maximum
impact was never
actually directly funded. At the time I did
it, we didn't
have a grant to develop a tetrahedral-mesh
solver for the
Euler equations when we wrote that airplane
code.
We had grants at NASA Langley and other
places.
All right. Well, it wasn't to do that.
And I didn't have any grant to do
aerodynamic design by control
theory. I got support later on from the
Air Force, but at the time I did it, it was
not funded.
So there's something I think I learned at
Grumman a little bit.
So my general approach at Grumman was that I
always did
whatever they asked me to do, even if I
thought it wasn't
necessary or that useful. But I could do it
fast enough
that I could still spend half the time, or
maybe even more
than half my time doing something that I
thought was
actually going to work. But I could do both.
That's a good—I think it's a good tip.
So be fast so you can do the other stuff as
well.
Yeah, exactly. So in fact, if you look at
sort
of young faculty, I mean, what you should do
is, all right,
you have a project that's safe and you've
got funding.
But now do that with say half the time and
spend the other
half trying something that's high risk and
way out there.
And if it doesn't work, you haven't lost
anything.
If it does work, you might have a big
impact.
Yeah. No, that's good.
That is very good. That is, that is good
advice.
Well, I am, I want to be appreciative of
your time.
I I really do Thank you so much. And I think
people will be able
to tell that your journey as you said, I
think that was a very
interesting point. I would argue that if you
had
done what you did shifted by five years,
your code may well
have been the Fluent, the STAR-CD of the
world.
You know, I think the fact that you did a
lot of your work, I
guess just before the boom in CFD, but that
does not mean that
your codes were not in some ways massively
the, the influence
for practically all the codes that people
use today.
So I think probably everybody who does CFD
today, particularly
in the aerospace sector owes a lot of what
they do to what you
did. And that, you know, I think
everybody should be and, and I'm sure are
very thankful for all
your work. And of course, all the, I didn't
mention it, but you have supervised so many
students who
have now gone on to be leading professors
and engineers in
their field who I know, who are appreciative
of you.
And probably by the time this comes out, you
will have reached
your 90th birthday. So I also wanted to say
happy
birthday. Maybe you're not now, but by the
time it comes out, it will be. So I hope
that when people are
listening to this, they will also say the
same thing.
Thank you.
One other thing I'm going to
mention: I did finally write a book, and I'm
not
completely satisfied with the book because
it's got an awful
lot of errors and typos and things like that
in it.
Somehow trying to straighten out the LaTeX
and get the same fonts all over the place
wound up
introducing mistakes as fast as trying to
correct them.
But still, the book's fairly comprehensive.
And when I look back, Horace Lamb's
Hydrodynamics book—it's
still useful. You know, it was actually
written in the 19th century. But still, some
aspects of
aerodynamic theory, at least for potential
flow, were all laid
out in Lamb's book. So whether anything that
I've done will
actually be of any interest 100 years from
now,
it's not at all clear to me, but it would be
nice to know.
I'm sure. Yeah, I'm sure it will be, and
I'll put
a link to your—it's Computational
Aerodynamics,
isn't it? I think that's the book from
Cambridge University Press. Yeah, it's got
a—
I'll put a link in. —Regrettable number of
kind of
typos and things like that still, but it
does try to
lay out, you know, a kind of theoretical
analysis of CFD
methods, not just practical how you arrive
at schemes.
No, yeah. Building quite heavily on
those books.
Yeah. And those books are great for people
to get a hold—
Yeah. As you say, there's some
textbooks that people read that influence
what they did.
And I'm sure the same is true for yours.
So yes, I'm—I'm sure people will be looking
at that in 100 years and all the other
papers that you've—
Well, thank you again.
Like I said, I really appreciate it.
And yeah, it was a pleasure, a pleasure to
speak to you.
Right. Well, thank you.
I've enjoyed it actually.